hello and welcome I'm rod Hamato I'm a
product manager at Google cloud and in
this session I will be presenting an
overview of HP and data protection on
GCP we'll go over the catalog of H and
data protection capabilities for both
ayahs and pass workloads running on GC p
and i'm happy to share that I will be
joined by Jeremy Tinley from Etsy who
has graciously agreed to describe how NC
uses and benefits from some of these
capabilities let's get started
AJ and data protection solutions are
required to maintain business continuity
key business continuity objectives are
to guard against accidental data loss
due to user errors data corruption or
ransomware and to achieve resilience to
infrastructure failures such as zone
failures component failures or even
failures of entire regions that could be
caused by natural disasters common h.a
and data protection solutions that
enable business continuity include
backups cross zone high availability and
cross region replication and dr
orchestration these solutions form a
spectrum with respect to the level of
resiliency that they provide and their
cost and the choice of any one solution
for a workload
depends on the business criticality of
the workload as well as the tolerance of
that workload to downtime for example
workloads that can tolerate a higher
recovery time could employ backups for
protection against both user errors and
infrastructure failures whereas mission
critical workloads that have stringent
uptime requirements would typically use
replication based solutions for
protection from infrastructure failures
and in addition to that use backups for
protection from user errors now it has
meant above where your workload is in
the spectrum our goal and GCD is to
provide a rich catalog of built-in data
protection primitives as well as is we
partner products to help design in
business continuity solution that is
aligned with the needs of your business
GCP compute story
and many paths services offered a wide
range of replication and backup
capabilities these primitives service
building blocks that can help you form a
business continuity solution in addition
to that we have a rich ecosystem of ice
we partner products that augment the
primitives available on GCP and support
a wide variety of use cases from
protecting GCE VMs to enterprise
applications such as sa B to replicating
entire VMware environments from on
premises to GCP for disaster recovery
various protection mechanisms can be
employed for protecting application
workloads running on GCP managed
infrastructure let's take a deeper look
at some of these H a and data protection
primitives to achieve high availability
in the event of infrastructure
unavailability such as zone failure
viens and containers can be distributed
across zones in a region similarly both
persistent disk and GCS offer regional
instances that replicate data across
zones in a region capabilities such as
VM machine images and persistent disk
snapshots enable backing up off both VM
configuration as well as application
data and similar backup capabilities are
in the pipeline for anthis gke clusters
as well as cloud file store geo
redundant cloud storage skills helped
replicate data across regions for
disaster recovery and dr orchestration
is enabled by deployment manager now in
addition to compute and storage
primitives we are adding primitives in
the near future to aid in application
consistent backups such as persistent
disk can act consistent snapshot hooks
and SMP certified back-end agents for
Google Cloud storage GCB past databases
and analytics services also pack in a
rich set of replication and backup
capabilities manage databases such as
cloud spanner and turbine table offer
modes for cross zone and cross region
replication
clogs equal HEA instances and Google
bigquery regional instances provide high
availability against zone failures for
data backups pass databases on GCP offer
primitives such as manage backups as
well as the ability to export data and
industry standard formats cloud sequel
also enables granular recovery form from
user errors or application corruption by
a point in time recovery having looked
at primitives suited for iies and pass
workloads running on GCB let's look at
how one of our customers is using GPS
business continuity primitives as
building blocks in their data protection
strategy I am pleased to welcome Jeremy
Tinley senior staff engineer on NZ's
database infrastructure team to share
insights from their protection strategy
for NC com welcome Jeremy thanks Radha
I've been at Etsy for six years and over
that time the infrastructure is
considerably evolved we recently
migrated to Google cloud and this gave
us a chance to rethink our general to
your strategy Google Cloud offers a wide
range of services for dr selecting and
more importantly adopting them was very
important to us but first a little bit
about Etsy Etsy is a global online
marketplace where people come together
to make sell buy and collect unique
items so who sells on Etsy Etsy sellers
are people from all over the world they
use their incredible talent to make
things this can be blankets made in
Morocco jewelry from Ecuador or even
soap made in Seattle they can also be
people who have vintage items that
they're finally willing to part with on
the flip side of the marketplace you
know buyers Etsy buyers browse the
marketplace looking for items based on
personal style or need my current
favorite is buying handmade chocolate
truffles I usually buy them locally made
from somebody who's in my community who
is my neighbor
and that also helps because the shipping
is really quick my favorite thing about
Etsy though is that they enable a human
to human connection you're not buying
something from a warehouse you're buying
it from a human being
working at Etsy is a bit similar humans
are crafting
structure and code hence our phrase code
is craft with that let's review our
architecture Etsy is a traditional lamp
stack consisting of Linux Apache my
sequel and PHP since Etsy is an
e-commerce marketplace you can probably
imagine a typical interaction with the
website a seller lists new items by
entering in the night the name the
pricing and description buyers browsing
Etsy get to read the sellers content
they can initiate a conversation with
the seller asking them questions about
their products they add an item to their
cart and hopefully they purchase after
they've made a purchase they can track
the shipping status and when they
receive their item they can leave
ratings and feedback for the store both
the front-end and back-end services run
on Google compute engine VMs not on a
hosted platform we do this because we
want more hands-on control over the
systems on the front end we use manage
instance groups to maintain availability
of web and API servers this makes it
trivial to add or remove capacity and
failing servers are deapool
automatically our front-end workloads
are stateless and this makes is
straightforward to manage disaster
recovery moving to the backend however
is where things get complicated
from the description above you can
surmise that we run a traditional OLTP
workload all of the data that buyers and
sellers generate and interact with is
stored in MySQL from a dealer point of
view we primarily rely on my sequel
native replication for multiple copies
of data we execute periodic snapshots of
our data and for each one we run a
restore test process to validate it for
transaction logs we sync those to Google
Cloud Storage buckets on a scheduled
basis however our world wasn't always so
wonderful
Etsy is 15 years old and for most of
that it was hosted in a traditional data
center with bare metal servers the good
news about running your own data center
you can manage everything the bad news
you have to manage everything so let's
look at one specific case dealing with
hardware failure I think we can all
agree that computers are both amazing
and also terrible hardware failures
especially discs happen this meant that
we need to be able to rebuild servers as
the need arose this was especially
painful when doing
large amounts of data in my sequel the
first step was just a provision of
bare-metal server on a good day an hour
was optimistic on a bad day we would
fight with UEFI settings boot disk
issues and on anaconda was not a good
friend let's assume that all that goes
correctly though after we've built our
bare metal server we have to restore my
sequel data we copy our data over the
network decrypt and decompress it bring
a database online and wait for
replication to catch up although it was
all automated it still took a long time
to perform many hours this same slow
down translated to our backup process we
ran into a longer than desired RTO or a
recovery time objective for my sequel
data backups were being performed daily
backups took about three hours to
complete which for us was painfully slow
these backups were full backups sent
over a network to specific backup
servers that had lots of disks floated
in them however the process doesn't end
there as the old adage goes a backup
isn't a backup until it's been tested
once our backup was transferred a
restored test process was kicked off to
verify that the data could be recovered
this involved once again copying the
full backup over the network to a
restore testing server decrypting and
decompressing bringing the database
online and waiting for replication to
catch up as I said before that whole
process took multiple hours to achieve
when these problems are magnified at
scale both for the amount of data and
copies of data it begins to stress the
infrastructure Etsy ran many many copies
of data each with a different purpose we
have our main production workload it has
redundancy we have geographic redundancy
and others were artificially delayed to
allow faster online recovery in the
event of an inadvertent data change
thankfully late in 2018 we migrated
etsy.com
to Google cloud in our relatively new
cloud world we found easier solutions to
these problems as I said earlier the
front-end takes advantage of
management's and scripts to improve the
speed at which failed nodes are replaced
the host has failed the host is
destroyed and it's rebuilt the host is
added back to production when it's
register is healthy before this magic
discs would have to be replaced host we
have
we built by hand no one has been asked
to pay attention to these issues anymore
this frees them up to focus on other
areas of improvement our New Mexico
environment was designed to take
advantage of native Google cloud
features the big shift was to use
persistent discs instead of local disks
we built our databases with one boot
disk for logs and state data like hid
files and lock files the second disk is
only for my sequel data performing a
live disk snapshot in my sequel is no
pun intended a snap there's no need to
quiesce a database either when my sequel
starts up its treated like a crash and
it recovers itself by using persistent
disks we got very easy differential
backups with PD snapshots coming from
the world where we did full backups
every single day this improved our
backup times from two to three hours
down to three minutes we can now take
many snapshots per day giving us the
ability to rollback data to a previously
known good point this eliminated the
need for an online delayed copy also our
snapshots are multi-region so we no
longer have to manage shipping full
backups across the entire us our restore
trust process is similar as it was
before with some wins after we obtain a
snapshot we again do a restore test
however this time in DCP were able to
provision a new VM dynamically we create
and attach a new disk from a snapshot we
bring my sequel fully online and have it
replicating by taking more frequent
snapshots replication cache our time was
significantly reduced this process used
to run for hours we can now test a copy
of data in just 15 minutes
another big win was to use Google Cloud
Storage we consistently send our
transaction logs to a bucket with
lifecycle management enabled this helps
us maintain a retention policy that
makes sense for our use case including
automatic merging of files when they
aged off and let me tell you legal is
really happy with that one our buckets
are also multi regional giving us
Geographic redundancy with our backups
just like our snapshots
although this translates to stress-free
disaster recovery recapping our results
we saw a big benefit with our migration
at Google cloud front-end server bills
are much faster and automatic on the
backend we
a tremendous improvement in RTO both the
speed at which we can provision down to
how quickly the data can be brought
online I think we've just scratched the
surface with what's possible we plan on
looking at additional DNR services that
can be leveraged to make our life easier
these results might have been possible
in a traditional data center but it
would require additional staffing
infrastructure and capacity management
as someone who participates in an
alcohol rotation I'm quite happy to
offload those challenges to Google cloud
pasture me for the insightful
description of the impact you've seen by
use of HHA and data protection
primitives as part of your JCB stack
from backup of data discs to replication
of transaction logs to use of highly
available managed instance groups for
web servers the solution shared by
Jeremy is representative of how
primitives across the spectrum can be
used for different components of your
workload based on the needs of your
business this concludes our overview of
haan data protection capabilities on GCP
thank you for joining us